she started off as a villain not caring
for link or anyone else other than
herself and her own personal goals for
revenge
she was only stuck with links simply
because she temporarily needed him
but then something happened somewhere
along the way this little
devilish flying imp developed a heart
for our boy in green
and was even willing to sacrifice her
own life for his
and his world of light this gradual
change of heart that all players were
allowed to witness firsthand
led to her ultimately becoming the most
beloved side character of all time
in a zelda game you know who i'm talking
about midna
the twilight princess fans adore this
intelligent
borderline psychotic character so much
that she has been the most requested and
most speculated over character to return
in a future zelda game and even though
mr aonuma
the series's producer stated that
midna's return was unlikely due to the
way twilight princess ended he
also said that if enough people wanted
her return how could they say no
and yet even though the voices wanting
her return have grown massively loud at
times
we're left with no midna well except for
her appearance in hyrule warriors but
those games don't really count i'd like
to focus on the first part of his
statement in this video
the part where he said that she probably
wouldn't return due to the way twilight
princess ended
we know that at the end of the game
midna shattered the mirror of twilight
which is the only known relic capable of
passage into the twilight realm
but what if there is more to this
statement than meets the eye
what if midna can't return because she's
dead
[Applause]
the three biggest clues that led to this
theory being created are the fact that
midna was already killed once by
ganondorf
sheds a magical tear to shatter the
mirror and dissolves in a different way
than anyone shown previously when she
transports herself into the twilight
realm for the last
time but really it all comes down to the
mirror you see
there are certain criteria that need to
be met in order to do what midna did at
the end of the game
to start with you can't just shatter the
mirror of twilight it's actually pretty
much indestructible according to some
in-game dialogue we're able to read
in fact zant was only able to separate
the mirror into four pieces by use of an
immense
dark power which was revealed to
originate from ganondorf
whose power comes from the triforce of
power meaning quite literally that not
even the triforce of
power could shatter the mirror of
twilight so midna's actions at the end
of the game are quite
extraordinary to say the least and just
so we're all on the same page
let's talk about what exactly the mirror
of twilight is
real quick as most fans should already
know the mirror of twilight is a relic
that uses
light to provide passage to and from the
realm of twilight it's located deep
within the sands of the gerudo desert
inside the
ancient prison known as the arbiter's
grounds its reasoning for being located
here is due to the fact that it was
originally used for the banishment or
exile of hyrule's most terrible
criminals and prisoners
the ranks of which include some familiar
faces like ganondorf or more importantly
the interlopers who dared to defy the
will of the gods
however i don't believe it was the gods
who made this mirror since their other
created relic
also known as the triforce which you may
or may not have heard of once or twice
shares no resemblance in design or
material to this strange mirror i also
don't believe that it was created by the
interlopers which is a theory that
exists in some corners of the internet
as it wouldn't make much sense for the
interlopers to create their own
banishment relic and then be powerless
to stop it
i believe it was instead the light
spirits that the gods created with the
express purpose
of banishing the interlopers who made
the mirror of twilight in order to
banish
said interlopers since that fits best
with the original purpose of both
parties and the mirror operates on
well light as a medium but we'll get
into that a bit later in the video
the strangest thing about the mirror is
that it has a legend associated with it
which states that only the true
ruler of the twilight can destroy it now
this
doesn't make that much sense given what
i just talked about i mean why would a
relic that was created
by the light spirits in order to banish
the interlopers to the twilight realm
who are the ancestors of the twilight
people be able to be destroyed
by the ruler of the twiligh if the
twilight people who are descendants of
the interlopers and therefore got their
dark magics from
said interlopers could have destroyed
the mirror whenever they wanted then why
would they have ever been banished in
the first place
the light spirits would have been like
ha look what we made to banish you and
the interlopers would have just gone
skid douche and there'd be no more
mirror something just doesn't add up
here unless
you change the context of the mirror's
legend about its destruction
what if it wasn't really a statement of
power but rather
a prophecy as in what if they weren't so
much saying yeah whoever sits on this
throne rightfully can destroy the mirror
but we're more saying
one day the true ruler of the twilight
will destroy the mirror
looking at this as a prophecy it makes
more sense as to why the twilight
weren't able to destroy the mirror
before midna the true ruler of the
twiligh but while it serves to answer
that question
it also creates another why then was
midna a twilight being
able to destroy the mirror what is midna
now i'd like to focus on the first clue
i touched on earlier the fact that midna
was killed by ganondorf you see at the
end of the game when link and midna team
up to take on ganondorf and defeat him
both as his puppet zelda form and as the
dark beast ganon
at this point zelda's essence which had
previously been infused into midna
returns to zelda restoring her spirit to
her body once again
after this happens ganondorf in the form
of angry fire starts looking real
threatening and minna decides to take
him on mano imano
she warps link and zelda out into hyrule
field before they can intervene and
engages in combat against ganondorf
the confused and concerned duo looks
around for a bit out there in the field
before finally seeing ganondorf appear
on horseback
holding a piece of midna's fused shadow
that she was wearing
in his hand and crushing it effortlessly
this
is heavily implied to be the first death
of midna
as ganondorf would have had to defeat
her to remove this fused shadow piece
from her
and for some reason i highly doubt he
was willing to let her off with a
warning
after their fight but yet after link
defeats ganondorf once and for all and
drives the master sword through his
chest
we get to see midna's revival but
something about this
also seemed off in a way as not only was
she revived and restored to her original
form
as ganondorf's curse was lifted the
light spirits were present all around
her for some reason
odd since she really doesn't have
anything in common with them and the
last time she was around a light spirit
as a being of twilight it almost
killed her fast forward to her departure
from the world of light not only is she
now
walking around freely without any harm
from the light but
she uses a tear to destroy the mirror
which seems to me like a very particular
detail that we should definitely read
way too much into you see we've seen
tears like this one before
in this very game actually the tear that
midna sheds is made
of light and looks very similar to a
tear of light shed by the light spirits
earlier in the game link has to collect
these tiers to restore the light spirits
and dispel twilight from their land
this similarity is more than just visual
however as it accomplishes what not even
the power of the triforce could
it shatters the mirror of twilight if
you apply the fact that the light
spirits are most likely the ones
responsible for the mirror's creation
and the fact that their tears are used
to dispel
twilight it makes sense that a light
spirit's tear could shatter the mirror
of twilight but
how could midna shed a tear of light
what magic from the twilight or the
interlopers would have granted this
power
how does this make any sense well if
you've been paying really close
attention to what i've been saying so
far
you might already know where i'm going
with this let's fast forward one more
time until the moment she leaves this
world
as i mentioned at the start of the video
midna dissolves like everyone else who's
passed through the mirror before her
but she does so as particles of light
something not even beings of light or
even she herself did when passing
through the mirror previously
so here we have a twilight being that's
been resurrected by light spirits who
can freely exist in the world of light
sheds a tear of light to shatter the
indestructible mirror of twilight and
dissolves into particles of light when
traveling to the world
of twilight ladies and gentlemen i
present to you
midna the light spirit i believe that
given the proof we just talked about
the light spirits must have infused her
with the power of light
as they did once before but this time to
resurrect her at the end of the fight
against ganondorf
turning her not only into a being of
light but into a light spirit like
themselves
now as cool as that sounds it's about
time i covered the real point of this
video
the actual death of midna you see just
like a being of twilight cannot exist in
the light
the same must be true for a being of
light to exist in the twilight
when midna transported herself into the
realm of twilight for the last time at
the end of twilight princess
i believe she knew that she wouldn't be
able to exist on the other side
think about it didn't she seem strangely
distracted trying to mask an almost
eerie undertone of sadness the whole
time she was giving her goodbyes to link
and zelda
it would seem that something deeply
depressing was on her mind as she was
very dismissive of zelda's comments on
how they were meant to co-exist
knowing that she was about to make sure
they would never co-exist again
but why would midna do something as dark
as this
well i think this requires a little bit
of a delve into her character to answer
you see even though midna turned a new
leaf in the events of the game and
learned to care for others instead of
just herself
deep down she was still the same midna
to call midna prideful would be an
understatement
i mean she was so upset at zan for
dethroning her
and embarrassed at her new implac form
that she literally
abandoned her own people in their time
of need something she grew to regret
later in the game
i think that either due to her sense of
duty or even her sense of shame
she was hell-bent on returning to her
people in the realm of twilight
eventually but her acts of heroism in
the world of light
led to her needing to be resurrected and
when she was resurrected as a light
spirit
she then realized she would never be
able to exist in her world again
and all of a sudden the twilight
princess was a wanderer
not belonging in the world of light or
the world of twilight but as stubborn as
she was
nothing could stop her from returning to
the twilight and she couldn't risk
having link or zelda use the mirror to
eventually enter the world of twilight
only to not be able to find midna
because she would no longer exist
so in her final moment knowing it was
her time to depart from her beloved
friends
she shed a tear of light and used it to
make sure her friends would always
remember her
as she was and that is my theory on the
life
resurrection and death of the twilight
princess and i know this was a heavier
one but what did you guys think did
midna die at the end of twilight
princess
giving credit to what aonuma said or
maybe she's still alive over there but
exists as a spirit like the other beings
of light or something else entirely
let me know in the comments below hey
guys thank you so much for watching
this one as sad as it was was still a
very interesting topic that i really
enjoyed delving into
please be sure to leave a like below to
get this video spread around as far as
it can go on youtube space
and be sure to subscribe to the channel
to stick around for more nintendo
related theories and content
as always huge thanks to my amazing
supporters of which i have some new
names to introduce
say hello to desiree s alex j and
fishbowl505 who have all joined the
ranks of my elite bandit crew
thank you guys so much and if you
watching are interested in helping the
next video come to life
feel free to check out that blue join
button located below or follow the links
to my patreon in the description
also down there are the links to my
social media pages which you should
absolutely check out to follow me over
on instagram
that's all i've got for this one so as
always i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day
this is massington abandoned signing out
[Music]
peace
[Music]
hahaha